hello everybody my name is markiplier
hell was it someone there
what the hell is that oh it sounded like
a crash I'll figure it out later some
projects fell okay so hello everybody
I'm here playing kilobyte still
wondering what that was but anyway we're
gonna play this game I got it from
gamejolt it's um another a pixelated
horror game are supposed to be like that
so let's just a little low low low low
low low okay let's just go into it kill
a difficulty make a difficulty Giga or
tera let's just try mega for now in a
few moments the Sun will not rise 12
cedis remaining oh oh it's like it's
gonna be all it's gonna be like this eh
okay so this is like oh man what was
that game I played I can't remember
hello CD is this a CD was that a CD ah
okay pick it up with the left mouse
button oh I can't remember the game I
play before but I remember it was
terrifying
fun times are these doors or something
okay I can't go in those Oh is somebody
out there in the darkness waiting didn't
was that whoa what the hell sounds like
old style not even doom Wolfenstein
music that's what it sounds like so some
of these I can rip down or bust open
with my giant muscles
let's freak me out what is going on here
some something's not right here some
feels wrong I mean with that whatever
the hell happened in my kitchen living
room area I don't know okay Larrin is a
gun
no that was something else
what the hell is that some someone's
banging what did I just pick up whoa
where did I go whoa hold on to your
niblets there hold on there buddy let me
get a hold on what's going on here
I think someone's hammering outside or
something I might may not have been in
my room that might be outside okay I
might be freaking out for nothing
it's not good to be hanging out and be
like here random screams coming from our
room like what the hell's going on
there's someone getting murdered up
there is there a little baby crying oh
haha
what hell are you what the hell with
that
what happened what do what do dammit
what new hell
what do hell is go on what do hell is
happen another CD another one of these
things I think batteries that's what
that is
these are batteries okay got those good
is there supposedly a margarine arugam
how must be either getting extremely
lucky where this place is not that big
okay okay okay
ah
ah I died
what do hot now inaudible to me done we
were banging on my door is some weird
thing oh that is syntax error purging
humanity oh thank you
damn it it was close maybe I don't know
hey like four to go
I didn't make it I can't remember the
name of the game that I played there was
like this ah I'm a big baby I got
trapped in a corner that was my fault
everything I do is my fault why am I
even wondering okay carry on
getting away from that thing I know
we're from the random noises in my new
apartment
okay all right but what the hell now I
used to be able to find tons of CDs now
I'm not finding any they were all over
the place before what the hell do happen
uh-huh
there's another one yay 12 more to go
man I've been through all over here
I haven't even found an inkling of them
sue ha ha ha why they all gonna be
blocked up open damn it opened ablet aah
knows any good finally I have a little
bit of hope ah Who am I kidding I have
no hope dammit I keep getting into dead
ends and then I have to go backwards and
then I'm probably gonna run into him and
then I'm already gonna die there we go
hello just go back ah this is gonna be
impossible because I'm gonna have no
idea where I've been no method of
backtracking I don't even know how I got
down to four before I think that means I
got 10 I don't even know how I did that
and I'm just never ridden every day
every night every day
yeah yeah I keep seeing these white dots
flying up from the ground here and I
keep thinking that there's something in
there actually nothing ah my eye
where is it where is it where am i where
am I going
what am i doing what am i doing where am
I going where am I going where we going
over that little sound zoomit near there
but I got it okay let's batter Go Go Go
Go Go Go damn damn damn damn
ah where that where that boo boo oh oh
man chooses to kill machine is designed
to okay that's fantastic I don't care
just let me be season 8 CDs remaining
wait what what really did it save my
progress why am I talking like this ah I
might be at an advantage here there are
less CT or make me maybe it just went
down to an easier difficulty because it
was like boy bargain what you're having
a lot of trouble on this we don't know
why but geez man get it together here
have a little bonus what CD yeah
look anyway I mean this layout on this
place is pretty huge I don't accept
I don't know how they expect me to win
give another the layout of it is so
convoluted and maze like and just the
general areas of the place are gigantic
I don't know what I'm gonna do Oh hold
me hold me I'm a big baby I'm a whining
baby
oh this bigoted I'm a whining baby
where where
I want to go home I wanna I want a hug a
teddy bear I want to eat that five pound
gummy teddy bear that I got where's it
where's it where's it oh my god
why do you always do the boo boo thing
when I'm trapped in a corner I'm out of
sprint already I haven't even seen the
monster and I'm already out of print
gimme battery no CD what kind of life is
this look at life is this this is my
life why do I choose to do these things
bu I don't want to be right behind right
I know it I know this I know this for a
fact he's right behind me huh is it dead
end
I got the walls to keep getting caught
on the walls and then I came out I hate
game like that if I if I was in real
life and I touch a wall I'd suddenly
cling to it like cling film velcro to
walls
oh there's not some cover-based shooter
where I attach to everything I touch
little little blue I've haven't found a
single damn CD anywhere ah I'm so bad
I'm so bad at games I'm too bad I suck
at games I can't do it I can't do it I
can't do it oh dude I'm done okay I'm
done I can't do it I'm so bad such a big
whitey baby a little why even I'm so
paranoid the whole damn time is cut
stupid noise I'm gonna go find out what
the hell that was started me off poorly
anyway so I'm all done here you could
try it for yourself the link is in the
description is from gamejolt it's pretty
good I like it it reminds me a lot of
the other one except that it actually
probably has an ending that I'm never
gonna find cuz I suck at games so anyway
you all so much for watching click the
annotations for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
Oh
bud
moving forward